elle les châteaux gonflables ont
remplacé les joué depuis le 23 novembre
fenland s'est installé à skywest à
montigny le bretonneux plus de 800
mètres carrés destiné aux enfants de 2 à
12 ans en premier la nouvelle politique
du centre qui s'axe entièrement sur de
loisirs et l'emplacement est idéal dans
un centre commercial c'est rare en
france c'est des structures qu'on
retrouve généralement en extérieur pour
bien passer un moment en famille les
parents peuvent quantité du centre
commercial ils peuvent profiter de faire
du shopping d'aller au cinéma et venir
après la séance de cinéma par exemple
donc c'est vraiment une sortie familiale
fondée par une société de location de
structures gonflables et d'événementiel
fun landes propose piscine à balles
animaux sauteurs et jeux de kermesse
c'est sympa ça permet d'avoir des
animations sont à côté de chez nous et
c'est très bien c'est super bien
foehn ont découvert les mercredis
samedis dimanches et pendant les
vacances scolaires et les équipes
proposeront bientôt un service de
garderie et des créneaux pour adultes
sont en train d'être pansées